7 juin 1951 le daily express paraissait
à londres avec un titre qui barrait
toute la première page et qui disait
ceci deux diplomates britanniques
disparus
et quand on lisait l'article on
apprenait que en effet deux diplomates
anglais avaient disparu de leur domicile
depuis le 25 mai précédents qu'ils
étaient passés sur le continent et qu'il
y avait les plus fortes raisons de
penser pour que ces diplomates
britanniques partent pour mot ce qu elle
ne délaisse pas s'ajouter que les
polices anglaise et française réunis se
trouvait au au travail à paris que l'on
passe est certes un quartier au peigne
fin et y compris montmartre car on
pensait que ces deux diplomates n'était
pas encore parti pour moscou mais on
voulait les retrouver avant leur départ
adonnant à 17 heures le même jour le
foreign office publie un communiqué il
confirme la nouvelle du daily express et
précise cette fois les deux noms il
s'agit de guy burgess et 2
donald mac les deux diplomates
britanniques en effet membres tous les
deux du foreign office et qui tous les
deux étaient partis pour moscou où on
allait retrouver quelques temps plus
tard le scandale fut immense on
apprenait que deux fonctionnaires du
foreign office étaient des agents
soviétiques certainement depuis très
longtemps qu'ils avaient donc pu livrer
à l'union soviétique des secrets
important et l'on accusait bien sûr les
services secrets britanniques le
gouvernement britannique
vous imaginez quel a été le ton de la
presse d'ailleurs vous vous souvenez
vous même probablement de ce qu'a été le
ton de la presse française avec mais
cette affaire qui a fait grand bruit il
ne faisait que commencer car
des années plus tard douze ans
exactement le 23 janvier 1963
un autre britannique avant le fils b
quitté beyrouth pour une destination
inconnue et cette destination allait
bientôt être très connu c'était
également moscow et là c'était pire
parce que phil b lui avait été l'un des
chefs du contre espionnage britannique
pendant des années philby s'était trouvé
au centre de tout le renseignement
britannique tous les secrets politiques
militaires civiles qui faisait la force
de l'empiré britannique était connue de
philby qui les avait transmis aux
soviétiques depuis très longtemps et
l'on apprenait de jour en jour du
nouveau et notamment que phil vie était
agent soviétique depuis probablement
1933 alors comment la faire burguès
mclean était devenue la sphère burguès
mclean fils biais bientôt n'allait plus
parler que d'affaires philby car
finalement le m le prince le héros le
traître numéro un
l'espion du siècle tout ce qu'on voudra
eh bien c'était filmé philby qu'ils
avaient agi en collaboration et en
accord toujours avec bernès et mac lui
comment tout cela avait il pu se
produire
comment tout cela avait il pu se passer
c'est ce que nous allons essayer si vous
le voulez bien de découvrir ensemble
alors la faire il faut bien toujours
trouvé une origine à une a fait la
sphère commence peut-être un jour
d'octobre 1929 quand à trinity college à
cambridge écoles fameuse collège fameux
lieu de rassemblement de la jeunesse de
l'establishment
quant à trinity college un jeune homme
de 17 ans par et pour y faire ses études
il s'appelle harold fils
il est blond il a les yeux bleus
il est plein de réserve de courtoisie il
est sympathique et il dit à ses
camarades d'emblée appelez-moi team
pourquoi kim et bien kim vous le savez
c'est une oeuvre de rudyard kipling et
c'était son père le père de harold
philby qui par admiration pour kipling
avait surnommé son fils kim le surnom
allait lui resté toute sa vie
aujourd'hui encore on parle de kembs
elbé pourquoi cette admiration pour
kipling et bien parce que le père qui
s'appelait saint john c'était son prénom
saint john fils b était un fonctionnaire
britannique aux seins
c'est là que kim était né en 1912
et puis pendant la grande guerre sainte
jones albi était devenu agent de
renseignement dans le moyen-orient il
s'était pris de cet amour fantastique
que certains britanniques ont éprouvé à
cette époque pour le moyen-orient penser
à lawrence d'arabie saint john philby
est un autre lawrence d'arabie et
peut-être une figure plus attachantes
encore que lawrence d'arabie
parce que au moyen-orient saint-john
fils bill lui a joué la carte d'un petit
prince a connu qui s'appelle ibn saoud
et auprès d'imf co2 il a fait en sorte
que secret l'arabie séoudite si l'arabie
séoudite aînés c'est à cause de saint
john felmy par la suite saint john
fields est devenu en 1925 le conseiller
dit mme zewde il s'est installé auprès
de lui il est devenu arabes se fait
appeler abdullah le serviteur du
seigneur a ajouté à son nom hadj le
surnom que peuvent prendre ceux qui ont
été à la mecque la conseiller privé
d'une cellule chargée d'importantes
affaires commerciales il était devenu
riche et puissant il avait été marié
bien sûr puisque kim philby était né en
1912 alors son épouse anglaise dora elle
vivait en angleterre
paisiblement avec ses enfants le petit
qui met trois soeurs pendant que
abdullah vivez prédit mme seo d'avec ses
autres femmes arabes c'est andy est
normal puisqu'il était musulman et voyez
vous je crois qu'il était important de
dire quelques mots de saint john philby
ça n'était pas remonté au déluge croyez
le bien
parce que harold philby kim philby la
vie qu'il va mener c'est une vie qui est
directement impressionné par celle de
son père le père est un magnifique
aventuriers lui kim philby va choisi un
autre va choisir un autre genre
d'aventuré mais toujours quand il se
lancera dans cette aventure c'est à son
père qu'il pensera ce père qui arrivé
quelquefois d'arabie à londres avec
cette allure étonnante ce ton impérial
cette qualité unique quels autres amis
du petit qui m'avait un père semblables
personnes il était à la fois terroriser
et admiratif et on sait que tout enfant
qui me file bien commencé à bégayer
savait que les psychologues disent que
le bégaiement chez en lançant n'est en
général d'un choc
on peut penser que le choc pour kim
philby a été cette apparition de temps à
autre du père qui surgissait de
l'inconnu alors il fait ses études
et puis un jour est arrivé l'âge de
l'université il arrive à trinity college
en 1929
l'année suivante à cambridge très
exactement en octobre 1930
un autre élève arrive celui là s'appelle
guy burgess
vous voyez que les héros nous les
retrouvons très tôt et guy burgess fait
de lui une entrée fracassante à
cambridge
c'est un dandy il est grand il est beau
il a une allure folle il est d'une
excellente famille les fils d'un
officier de marine décédé petit fils
d'un ami rallye les deux familles nobles
et il est intelligent comme on l'est
rarement il est brillant il peut être
les musiciens il dessine admirablement
il est champion de natation de football
de cricket et surtout il arrive lui qui
hier qui vient directement de
l'establishment
il arrive avec la volonté de tout casser
la première chose qu'il dit à ses
camarades un peu médusé tout de même
c'est je suis marxiste est homosexuel et
pour bien appuyer cette dernière
affirmation quand il arrivera effectué
par le premier soir et s'approche d'un
solide gaillard qui est un membre de
l'epic de l'équipe de roaring elle lui
dit des fois mon cher voulez vous
coucher avec moi ce soir ce sont des
choses évidemment qui font du bruit même
à cambridge alors il est là avec toute
une cour avec des petits amis
immédiatement innombrables il en aura
toute sa vie des quantités il plaît
beaucoup aux femmes et n'a que faire des
femmes
ce qui m'intéresse c'est lakers et à
côté de ça marxiste est à ce point
marxiste qu'il va fonder à cambridge
la première cellule communiste de la vie
de l'université à cette cellule va venir
kim philby et une amitié va se lier
entre eux philby et burgess amitié n'ont
pas placé sur aucun plan sexuel
car pour philby n'y a absolument aucun
soupçon à avoir mais sur un plan
uniquement politique
alors on peut se demander pourquoi ces
gens sont marxiste en 1930 à cambridge
alors qu'ils sortent de ces familles
bourgeoises et bien ils s'inscrivent
dans un climat
n'oublions pas que nous sommes juste au
plein de la grande crise de la grande
dépression et la commencer l'année
précédente
un jeudi noir à wall street et depuis
l'inflation s'est répandu sur l'amérique
et sur l'europe et le chômage
et tout ce qu'ils ont les suivis il y a
en angleterre des millions de chômeurs
il y a une jeunesse qui tout à coup
c'est veille à ces problèmes là une
jeunesse qui répudie en même temps le
parti travailliste parce que c'est parti
travailliste on considère qu'il a trahi
qui s'est trop palier avec les autres
classes avec les autres partis alors
qu'il cherche éperdument autre chose et
un lucide témoins de cette époque à
cambridge en bains a pu écrire avant
1929 le sujet de conversation à
cambridge
c'était la poésie après 1929 c'est la
politique
oui ces jeunes gens ce sont absolument
enragé de politique alors ils ne sont
pas tous communistes non mais y en a il
y en a il y en a pas mal d'autres qui
sont communisants d'autres qui sont de
gauche mais d'une gauche avancez disons
aussi que c'est une mode et des
historiens david lynch qui se sont
amusés à rechercher les revues de
trinity college à cette époque on
trouvait certain nombre de gens qui à
l'époque se proclamer extrêmement à
gauche et qui aujourd'hui sont des
diplomates extrêmement à six membres du
parti conservateur
il ya même le conservateur des tableaux
de la reine est paraît-il il chantait à
cette époque le drapeau rouge dans son
bas évidemment il a changé il ya même un
milliardaire puisque à l'époque était
d'extrême gauche lord rothschild
évidemment il a changé depuis mais il y
en a qui ne changent pas et burgess et
mclean ne change pas pour jeudi mclean
parce que en 31 est arrivé un troisième
élève lui c'est un jeune homme un peu
mou un peu la fatique le teint pâle il
est d'une bonne famille aussi il est le
fils d'un ministre libéral et lui aussi
est saisi par les idées de gauche est
lui aussi va se mettre à militer avec
ses camarades et lui aussi va se lier
avec bargueth et fils billets les voilà
tous les trois la trinité qui restera
former jusqu'à la fin des études alors
vous savez ce temps
fin des études arrivent c'est le temps
où en général on s'était cru liés pour
la vie où on se sait pas on se quitte on
ne se voit plus ce sera le cas pour
beaucoup ce ne sera pas le cas pour
philby mclean burgess qui se
souviendront peut-être toute leur vie de
ce spectacle insolite surgi à cambridge
un jour dans ce temple de la
respectabilité traditionnel britannique
les chômeurs les chômeurs avaient fait
irruption il marchait ils étaient des
milliers et il faisait ce qu'ils
appelaient la marche de la fin alors il
avait traversé cambridge et les récits
du temps nous démontrent les étudiants
de chaque côté des rues regardant
stupéfait des gens comme ils n'en voyais
jamais daigné avec des chaussures béante
et sur le visage une expression qu'il ne
connaissait pas celle que donne la fin
en août 1933 philby qui a quitté
définitivement cambridge se retrouve à
vienne pourquoi viennent bien il aime
vienne il est déjà allé à vienne l'année
précédente
son père lui a un jour donné de l'argent
pour acheter une motocyclette qui
l'achetaient matin sud est il sillonne
les routes d'europe pendant les vacances
il retourne à vienne on sait pas très
bien pourquoi ils ferment il va à vienne
et laïque de sang dans une famille
coleman c'est important parce que dans
cette famille coleman ya monsieur madame
coleman bien sûr il ya une fille de 23
ans qui s'appelle liszt qui a autrement
dit alice qui est charmante qui a déjà
été mariée à 18 ans déjà divorcé après
14 mois de mariage un petit personnage
comme vous voyez est évidemment il
arrive ce qui doit arriver
kim philby devient amoureux de la petite
liszt coleman ils deviennent amants et
viennent dans à la fin 1933 c'est
également la crise c'est la dépression
mondiale
mais c'est pire que ça c'est un pays qui
ne peut pas vivre depuis le traité de
versailles un pays avec une capitale
énorme et une province étriqué c'est un
pays où la moitié des citoyens est
ruinée où l'on la fin où le travail
manque évidemment chacun tente de tirer
parti de cette situation et le pays est
déchiré entre une gauche agissante une
droite de plus en plus agissante elle
aussi jeux ou des buts de 1934 c'est le
chancelier dollfus qui est au pouvoir et
mussolini lui conseille de se
débarrasser d'abord de la gauche pour
ensuite écrasé la droite ce qu'il fait
mon dieu et il écrase la gauche en
février 1934
c'est une véritable guerre civile cet
affreux quatre jours de bataille de
combats dans les rues de vienne
1020 wimille main or liszt est elle-même
une militante de gauche kim philby et
elles se sont bien rencontrés et ils se
lancent dans ces quatre jours de combats
du côté que vous pensez bien
alors un jour alors que les combats
s'achèvent par la mort de la gauche
philby va sauver six ouvriers qui sont
dans un égout ont leur procurant des
vêtements et puis c'est fini c'est le
grand silence on arrête on arrête à tour
de bras alors philby avec son passeport
anglais arrivent à faire fuir quelques
militants socialistes et communistes
vers l'étranger
et puis c'est liszt lead ce qui est en
danger on va l'arrêter elle aussi alors
une seule solution est la très vite sans
hésiter sans attendre il les pose c'est
une anglaise qui va quitter l'autriche
avec son nouveau mari
kim philby qui vont regagner tous les
deux l'antre et c'est un nouveau fil b
qui va tout à coup apparaître à londres
un film big qui ne proclame absolument
plus aucune idée de gauche 1 philby qui
pour ses camarades apparaît change et
puis vous savez on oublie vite et on
s'habitue aux nouveaux philby le nouveau
film be affiche un libéralisme de bon
aloi
disons très conservateur c'est un homme
qui penche et très évidemment vers la
droite et pour certains bien c'est une
évolution normale les illusions de
l'université sont oubliées sont
terminées et bientôt on s'habitue à ce
film be très très bourgeois très
conservateur très à droite c'est qu'il
s'est passé quelque chose dans la vie de
filmer
des gens sont venus le voir des
soviétiques des agents secrets
soviétiques
ils lui ont demandé s'il voulait se
mettre au service de l'idée communiste
internationale et nous savons que philby
n'a pas hésité c'est ce qu'il écrit dans
ses mémoires
ma guerre silencieuse paru chez robert
laffont dans ce livre il ne dit pas
tellement de choses sur son rôle d'agent
secret mais ce qu'il dit justement est
important à l'est quand il dit on m'a
abordée alors que j'étais très jeune je
n'ai pas hésité
et ça il faut y penser un instant parce
que un agent de puissances étrangères
vous aborderez ou mahb ordre et en
demandant de servir un autre pays que le
nôtre est bien nous refuserions lui
n'hésite pas probablement parce qu'il
est marqué par ce qu'il a vu à vienne
parce qu'il a ressenti à cambridge et
peut-être aussi parce qu'il n'est pas un
homme tout à fait comme les autres on
n'est pas un homme comme un autre si on
accepte de devenir espion et nous savons
que kim philby devenu agent soviétique
sans doute en 1933
on ne sait pas si c'est à cambridge
avant vienne ou si c'est après vienne
enfin c'est à cette époque là nous
savons que c'est philby devenu agent
soviétique qui très vite a présenté guy
burgess à ces nouveaux contacts
soviétique et guy burgess a été lui
aussi recruté un peu plus tard ce sera
le cas de donald ma clé est il devenu
burguès lui à la sortie d'université
bien burguès
était trop vieux pour passer des examens
et concours c'est est forclos pour lui
alors il est allé faire en voyage à
moscou
et il est revenu déçu à tout le monde il
a déclaré vraiment que ce qu'il avait vu
en russie n'avait rien à voir avec ce
dont il rêvait et avec éclat il a quitté
le parti communiste il est bien évident
que cette double évolution si rapide de
file burguès étaient téléguidés et qu'on
leur avait demandé à tous les deux
d'apparaître des hommes nouveaux
tant il est vrai qu'un agent n'est
efficace que si précisément ils ne
représentent pas les idées que son
action recouvrent leur burqa c'est mm
adressée au parti conservateur
désirant recevoir un emploi dans les
cadres du parti c'était peut-être un peu
rapide
alors là on lui avait dit non tout de
même qu'en fait il y avait ces petits
amis ça faisait quand même mauvais effet
il en avait tellement puis buvait déjà
beaucoup alors il était un jour aller
dîner chez des amis avec les des
rothschild la mère de son camarade de
cambridge
il était tellement brion tellement est
insolent qui l'avait blue et les des
rothschild laquelle lui avait confié dix
ans tenant et ça c'est sidérant
l'administration son portefeuille quand
on pense à ce que devait être le
portefeuille de valeurs mobilières de
lady rothschild et quand on pense qu
elle le confie à ce jeune homme de 25
ans est incroyable et l'important c'est
vrai et il paraît même qu'il ne s'est
pas trop mal débrouillé la preuve qui en
est qu'il est devenu un peu plus tard
conseiller financier pour d'autres
personnes de la société
et bien comme ça n'était pas un métier
bailly les deux il est entré à la bbc il
tentera la bbc l'avait beaucoup de
relations et à la bbc mon dieu il a bien
réussi il a créé une émission qui
s'appelait la semaine à westminster
qu'il présentait avec beaucoup de bagou
n'oubliez pas que nous sommes à l'âge
d'or de la radio et tous les
parlementaires voulaient passer dans son
émission la semaine à westminster comme
aujourd'hui tous les parlementaires
souhaitent passer à la télévision
c'était la même
très exactement et mon dieu burgess se
faisait d'immenses relation il est même
devenu l'ami de churchill à cette époque
et en même temps pour bien marquer son
évolution vers la droite vers alors vers
l'extrême droite
burgess milite dans les rangs d'une
curieuse association qui s'appelle
l'anglo jahman fait la hot chip
c'est à dire en quelque sorte les
amitiés anglo allemand c'est là que se
retrouvent une grande partie des gens en
angleterre qui commence à admirer avec
beaucoup de constance cette étoile
nouvelle qui s'est levé à l'horizon de
l'allemagne et qui s'appelle adolf
hitler et son parti national socialiste
on commence à certain nombre de
personnes en angleterre commença
admirait beaucoup heatley et burgess
rentrant dans l'association qui
précisément manifeste cette admiration
tous les jeux c'est beaucoup pour un
homme qui avait fondé la première
cellule communiste à cambridge mais ça
n'étonne pas tellement les gens qui
connaissent burgess toujours le même
raisonnement ben oui l'illusion de
jeunesse tout ça ça n'était pas sérieux
il est vraiment dans sa voie la plus
vrai maintenant celle qui vous convient
alors tout en étant la bbc on sait qu'il
commente nous sommes tout à fait entre
les deux guerres nous sommes vers 1936
il commence à donner des renseignements
aux services de renseignement
britanniques parce qu'il a beaucoup de
potentiel recueille beaucoup
d'informations il apprend beaucoup de
choses
et mon dieu il apporte des informations
qui intéressent le service de
renseignements britannique on les lui
prend il est en quelque sorte pigiste du
service de renseignement britannique
jusqu'au jour nous sommes en 1938 où on
le recrute à la section des du sdis et
csc la spéciale intelligence service
services secrets britanniques il y a
deux sections à cette époque importante
de services secrets en angleterre il y
avait six est ce qu'on appelle également
mi6 c'est à dire melide harry
intelligence et aussi le mi5 et le mi6
et chargé d'espionner à l'étranger c'est
l'espionnage sur l'étranger le mi5 c'est
l'espionnage à l'intérieur des
frontières de la grande bretagne
alors le section des est une section
spéciale une section sabotage et
propagande subversion qui est créée à
l'intérieur du sms et c'est dans cette
section que l'on recrute
burguès en 1938 maclean est bien mclean
lui à passer ces concours il est entré
au foreign office une sorte de voie tout
à fait le tracé al avance logique normal
il est entré au foreign office
et il trouve son premier poste à
l'ambassade de france
preuve qu'il est entré dans un bond à
l'ambassade deux à l'ambassade de
grande-bretagne en france et là il s'y
trouve peu de temps avant la guerre il
est un excellent fonctionner mais il a
une vie un peu double très bon
fonctionnaire sur la rive droite il va
régulièrement 0 il est très bien
puis sur la rive gauche bien une
fréquente le café de flore le café des
deux magots se lie avec le sculpteur
giacometti avec le poète tristan tzara
et c'est justement dans le café la
gauche que donald mclean rencontre une
jeune américaine qui s'appelle melinda
et cette jeune américaine
il en tombe amoureux nous sommes juste
avant la guerre de 1930 et film il faut
bien que je les prenne l'un après
l'autre et que je les suive tous les
trois puisque nous allons trouver leur
action entièrement un briquet alors
philby et bien philby appris un métier
il est devenu secrétaire de rédaction
dans un journal mensuel la review of
review c'est une tâche absolument sans
gloire et nous savons par lui-même qu'il
rencontre son contact soviétique
une fois par semaine et pendant deux ans
le contact soviétique ne lui demande
rien et ça c'est intéressant
qu'est ce qu'on veut on veut au fond
mettre à l'épreuve philby et cet homme
qu'il se sent utile en rien qui ne sert
à rien si on lui avait demandé d'emblée
quelque chose' il aurait eu conscience
d'exister dans la nouvelle fonction
qu'on lui demandait de remplir mais non
rien on lui demande rien et il va quand
même toutes les semaines au rendez-vous
alors la mise à l'épreuve
est positive et enfin on va lui demander
quelque chose après que lui aussi est
d'ailleurs adhéré à l'anglo german and à
l'anglo german fellowship aux amitiés
anglo-allemande ah oui lui aussi les
dans ce mouvement et même le 14 juillet
1936 il assiste un grand banquet en
l'honneur de la fille de kaiser et là on
peut voir sur la photo que nous avons la
manifestation on peut voir qu'il y as
sur les tables la signe de croix gammée
qui est répandu à profusion c'est ainsi
il donne maintenant la pression lui
aussi d'être un homme d'extrême droite
très admiratif du mouvement l'asie très
admiratif dix plaies et enfin on lui
demande de faire quelque chose
les soviétiques lui demande de faire
quelque chose c'est la guerre d'espagne
vous voyez à grant rennes c'est toute
l'histoire de notre siècle que nous
parcourons car ils sont mêlés à toute
cette histoire
ces sommes dont nous retraçons
l'histoire c'est la guerre d'espagne
franco a débarqué en espagne s'en est
pris au régime républicain et l'espagne
est divisé en deux les républicains qui
essayent de défendre le régime légal et
les nationalistes qui veulent remplacer
ce régime par celui de leur choix
alors les soviétiques décide d'envoyer
philby en espagne pas du côté
républicain
non du côté de franco et c'est ainsi que
avec des fonds remis par les soviétiques
par l'intermédiaire de bargueth philby
par bon l'espagne l'espagne du général
franco
et là il va avoir une couverture car il
enverra des articles au times et ces
articles seront aussi bon que le times
les prendre à ces articles il deviendra
correspondant spécial envoyé spécial du
times auprès des nationalistes et toute
la guerre d'espagne philby va la faire
dans les rangs nationalistes ayant pris
parti fait et cause pour les
nationalistes le 10 ans dans ses
articles à ce point qu'un jour
l'ambassade républicaine se plaindre à
se plaindre à au times du parti pris de
son envoyé spécial philby philby va
faire toute cette guerre va être le plus
élevé et des correspondants de guerre
demandant sans cesse des renseignements
même plus qu'il ne l'avait besoin pour
ses articles invitant des soldats des
officiers à dîner des espagnols des
allemands des italiens
questionnant sans cesse et états majeurs
mais nous savons maintenant nous le
savons par lui même que les
renseignements c'était pour les
soviétiques c'était pour ses patrons
qu'il l'ait recueillait il avait des
boîtes aux lettres en espagne en france
en angleterre et il avait le moyen
d'acheminer ces informations ce qu'il
faisait régulièrement
il avait même un code secret dont il
devait se servir pour les acheminer et
il avait le code de ce code si l'on peut
dire sur un petit papier qui ressemblait
un peu à une faille en papier de riz
qu'il avait en permanence sur lui dans
une poche de son pantalon et il a
raconté lui même comment un jour le vent
du boulet a passé
il était allé à cordoba assister à une
course de taureaux
il avait demandé avant de partir et ce
qu'il faut un laissez-passer pour corps
de banlieue avait du nom des accords de
bâle s'est avéré qu'il fallait aller
s'est passé et deux miliciens l'ont
arrêté parce qu'il n'avait pas se
laisser passer avec sa valise à la main
ils ont amené au poste de la milice
là il se trouvait devant un majeur et il
avait dans la poche sans ticket son
petit morceau de papier son petit
rectangle de papier avec son code secret
et si on trouvait ce code on aurait su
qu'ils étaient immédiatement et c'était
le peloton d'exécution leur pendant le
trajet il avait essayé de prendre ce
papier 2 de le faire disparaître
impossible et de miliciens ne l'avait
pas quitté d'un instant alors maintenant
il est dans le poste de la police et un
majeur qui l'interrogent les deux
miliciens
on fouille sa valise et lui qui essaye
toujours de faire disparaître son papy
n'y arrive pas on fouille la balise on
trouve rien eh bien à vous maintenant
deal majeur vos affaires retourner vos
poches votre portefeuille
et alors là c'est l'idée il prend le
portefeuille et le lance loin sur la
table lors les trois hommes plongent
pour attraper le portefeuille lui prend
la main dans sa poche ramène le papier
le met dans la bouche
laval personne n'a rien vu il est sauvé
mais il dira qu'il a eu très chaud
le 31 décembre 1937 il est parti avec
trois autres correspondants de guerre de
saragosse pour le front de thé ruelle
la voiture s'arrête dans un village tout
près du front et tout à coup une
explosion énorme
c'est un obus qui est tombé de plein
fouet sur la voiture les trois
correspondants sans ma fille lbi
nouvelle chance extraordinaire et
seulement blessé légèrement au front et
au poignet
trois mois plus tard au mois de mars le
général franco
sur le front des troupes décorera philby
lui mais de la médaille du mérite
militaire espagnol et puis c'est la
prise de barcelone la prise de moscou la
fin de la guerre pour ses amis
soviétique philby a fait de l'excellent
travail
il demandait d'être rappelé en
angleterre c'est fait et puis c'est la
guerre il a rencontré l'espagne une
jeune femme une canadienne une ancienne
actrice qui s'appelle france ce qui fait
que ses liens avec liszt se sont
évanouis la liaison avec francis a duré
à peu près tout le temps de la guerre
d'espagne et puis maintenant qu'il a
quitté l'espagne et l'oubli française il
rencontre une autre jeune femme qui
s'appelle hélène et là il épouse après
avoir divorcé de l'edsr elle lui donnera
cinq enfants c'est la femme peut-être
qui a le plus compté pour lui alors
c'est la guerre fois-là cette guerre qui
éclate presque l'aboutissement logique
normal de tout ce que nous avons raconté
jusqu'ici des crises des gays c'est
largué cette guerre qui va voir le
destin de sylvie burgess mclean tournait
définitivement la guerre revient philby
là commence d'abord à arras comme
correspondant de guerre pendant la drôle
de guerre laissant nuit abominablement
et puis enfin il quitte la france au
moment de la débâcle
maclean louis épouse melinda au moment
de la débâcle qui également la france
pro gagner londres le foreign office
burguès est toujours à la section des
est en outre 40 c burguès qui va
présenter à ses patrons des services
secrets britanniques
kim philby son ami le journaliste bien
connu
qui ambitionne à son tour d'entrer dans
les services agcs et fils be est admis
lui aussi à la section des du sdis du
special intelligence avait alors là il
faut s'arrêter un instant parce que
l'intégration de phil b dans les
services secrets britanniques c'est la
beauty c'est un aboutissement c'est un
point de départ un aboutissement parce
qu'il n'y a pas de doute que les
services secrets soviétiques eux quand
ils avaient choisi philby avait tracé un
chemin bien précis un chemin qui allait
tout droit vers les services de
renseignement on voulait qu'un jour
philby soit intégré dans ses services de
renseignement parce que là il pourrait
enfin donner des renseignements de
premier ordre aux soviétiques et voilà
c'était arrivé grâce à burgess un autre
agent soviétique
on l'avait intégré philby aux services
secrets britanniques
à quelques jours de la le sd la section
des plutôt fluette et cet autre chose la
section des sera supprimé et l'on créera
un autre organisme
la no1 c'est-à-dire section d'opérations
exécuté il s'agit également de sabotage
de subversion de propagande mais c'est
une section plus robuste que lens unis
l'ancienne section des sirops bus qu'on
élimine un certain nombre de personnels
de l'ancienne section des notamment
burguès parce que tout de même avec ses
beuveries avec ses petits amis
il fait pas sérieux mais alors paradoxe
burguès qui avait fait entrer philby est
éliminé et philby qui vient d'entrer lui
reste parce que lui il inspire confiance
alors là nous devons bien nous poser une
question comment se fait-il que on est
intégré harold philby kim philby dans
les services secrets britanniques sans
se renseigner sur ses antécédents car
enfin il existe et ses antécédents il y
avait d'abord son passé de militant
communiste à cambridge et ça disons que
c'était une information importante pour
le saut vers ses services secrets
britanniques mais il y avait autre chose
c'est qu'il avait été militant pro nazi
dans une association pro nazi que son
qu'il avait reçu une décoration général
franco que son père d'ailleurs le père
saint john philby de passage par
l'angleterre venait d'être interné pour
sympathies pro nazi tout ça n'empêchait
pas qu'on recrute et kim philby
tranquillement dans les services secrets
britanniques il semble qu'on ait fait
aucune enquête qu'on les trouvait ce
garçon bien sous tous rapports bonne
famille bonne allure les références du
times et thé ban aussi et on l'a recruté
comme ça sans aucune enquête ce qui
donne évidemment certaines idées des
services secrets britanniques à cette
époque il allait changer heureusement
par la suite
alors il est dans la place il passera
bientôt en 41 la section des inspections
des qui est non pas la section des à la
section 5 qui elle est la section du
contre espionnage
alors c'est fini maintenant il est au
plein du service secret dans la section
la plus renseigné la plus importante
la section doit dont doivent rêver tous
les autres services secrets bien il est
là il est dedans et tout ce qui s'y
passera désormais le dira chaque semaine
à ses amis soviétique
de quoi qu'il chargeait bien notamment
du contre-espionnage en espagne au
portugal
il s'agit de dépister les agents
allemands qui recueille partout des
informations et qui peuvent donner ces
informations aux sous-marins allemands
lesquels peuvent couler la flotte
britannique flotte américaine
il faut dire que philby fait du bon
travail pendant ces années là il des
pistes un grand nombre d'agents allemand
et disons que pendant ces années là il
n'est pas totalement critiquable
puisqu'il se trouve que la russie et
l'angleterre sont alliés dans la même
guerre contre le même ennemi et que le
travail qu'il fait qu'il fait pour l'un
et bien elle le fait aussi pour l'autre
et que mon dieu c'est positif
et voilà que justement s'achève cette
guerre
et voilà que justement à yalta churchill
rencontre staline avec roosevelt et
churchill se pose des questions on se
demande si réellement le chemin qu'on
pourra suivre après la guerre avec les
soviétiques sera facile et peut-être ne
serait-il pas mauvais de se prémunir
contre certaines difficultés justement
c'est ainsi que bien avant la fin des
hostilités ont créé wacey s la section 9
qui est une section d'espionnage
antisoviétique et alors là les maîtres
de philby n'ambitionne plus qu'une chose
c'est que dans cette section dont ils
savent bien qu'elle va prendre une
grande extension que dans cette section
ce soit justement philby qu'on fasse
entrer peut-être philby qui la dirige
alors on donne l'ordre à philby de tout
faire pour ça et philby va mener là une
stratégie extraordinaires supérieur
s'en prenant à tous les obstacles qui le
séparait du but et a accompli des
patrons des amis tant pis n'y avait que
le but qui comptait alors les uns après
les autres pour des raisons ou d'autres
raisons
les l'obtient qu'on les élimine il reste
l'obstacle le patron de la section 5
c'est à dire car guerre ce sont deux
vieux amis ils s'aiment bien mais tant
pis le gac le but à atteindre
alors qu il est bien chez lui obtient
qu'il soit éliminé
on demande sa démission à cog hill qu'on
l'accuse d'un certain nombre de victimes
est le patron le grand patron general
mills appel filmer
et lui dit j'ai pensé à vous pour
prendre la direction de la section 5 mai
la section 9 n'est plus utile c'est
devenu maintenant le principal de nos
préoccupations
alors nous allons joindre la section 9
et la section sac vous allez diriger
tout cela philby et philby naturellement
accepte et toutes ces années de lutte
souterraine d'ambition calculé sont
couronnés ce jour là la section 5
le contre-espionnage tout le contre
espionnage britannique comprenant le
contre espionnage contre l'union
soviétique bien maintenant c'est philby
qui dirige tout cela philby qui sait
tout qui sera tout et qui communiquera
tous à ses maîtres solide alors cela
durera des mois de longs mois et des
mois pendant lesquels philby sera à même
de livrer beaucoup d'informations avec
encore une fois peut-être le vent du
boulet qui passe parce que au mois
d'août 45 à istanbul à vice-consul
soviétique qui s'appelle volkov se
présente à l'ambassade de grande
bretagne demandent à voir un
fonctionnaire et lui dit je veux passer
à l'ouest
avec ma femme alors je demande asile
premièrement deuxièmement une somme
d'argent pour vivre et j'apporte en
échange tout l'organigramme des services
secrets soviétiques
et puis aussi j'apporte les noms de nos
agents à l'ouest et notamment
je suis à même de vous nommer de
fonctionnaire du foreign office qui sont
agent soviétique depuis longtemps est
l'un des chefs de l'espionnage
britannique qui est un agent soviétique
alors on reçoit ces informations à
l'ambassade istanbul mais on les envoie
immédiatement à londres immédiatement
c'est à dire que volkov a supplié qu'on
n'en voit pas les informations pas par
câble par télégramme parce que dit il
les soviétiques connaissent depuis
longtemps les codes britannique
depuis que nous connaissions l'existence
de file bis nous n'en doutons pas alors
on a envoyé par la valise diplomatique
le rapport c'est le général man c'est ce
qu'il a sous les yeux et le général 26
ayant cette information capitale appel
quitte pour en parler va naturellement
le responsable de la section 5
le responsable de l'espionnage
antisoviétique c'est lui et ses fils vie
qui a sous les yeux maintenant le
rapport
voilà ce qui menace ce qui menace
peut-être d'un jour à l'autre
il ya un homme qui dit à istanbul si
vous ne recevez je vous dirais je vous
dénoncerait trois agents soviétiques à
londres dont l'un des chef de
l'espionnage
va-t-on laisser parler que faire alors
commence une extraordinaire lutte contre
la montre philby souhaite immédiatement
partir pour istanbul pour rencontrer
lui-même volcan vous parer aux dangers
qui se précise malheureusement 26 veut
envoyer quelqu'un d'autre ce quelqu'un
d'autre est désigné mais ce quelqu'un
d'autre n'aime pas l'avion refuse 24
heures de gagner c'est philby finalement
qui part il prend l'avion pour istanbul
mais tempête au dessus de malte l'avion
est dérouté sur tunis s'arrête 24 heures
encore on attend 24 heures pour repartir
pour le caire au caire on manque la
correspondance pour istanbul 24 heures
hockey et on arrive seulement le
vendredi à istanbul vendredi kelby
philby se rend à l'ambassade veux parler
de volkov ne lui dis attention
impossible il faut le feu vert de
l'ambassadeur mais c'est le week end
anglais et il ne pourra voir philby
l'ambassadeur que le dimanche sur son
yacht
l'ambassadeur le dimanche lui donnera le
soler c'est donc le lundi matin que
philby tentera de joindre folk of au
consulat général soviétique
elle a une voix dira volkov messieurs
volkov mais il est parti pour moscou
et on apprendra en effet qu'un avion
s'est posé sur l'aérodrome d'istanbul un
avion soviétique qu'une ambulance a
quitté le camp suis là qu'un homme sur
une civière a été transporté à
l'aérodrome que cet homme a été chargé
dans l'avion ainsi philby qui
naturellement avait prévenu ses contacts
soviétique à londres dès le premier jour
avait laissé le temps aux agents
soviétiques de prévenir moscou lesquels
avaient prévenu istanbul on avait
récupéré volkov philby été sauvés mais à
la limite
quant à volkov mais philby n'était pas
homme à se préoccuper de wolf en 46 il
partira de nouveau pour istanbul où il
sera agent pratiquement chef de tous les
espionnages antisoviétique danse est la
plaque tournante à cette époque là il
parcourt la frontière il photographie
noir à ras el ras dans son bureau
plus tard cette photographie du mont
ararat et on s'étonnera certains
s'étonneront diront mais votre
photographie est inversé oui duras fil
beewi c'est comme salle est inversée ce
que personne ne devinera c'est qu'en
fait la photographie n'a pas été prise
du côté turc
mais du côté soviétique parce que fils
bien et si près que mon dieu il
franchissait temps en temps la frontière
pour aller voir ses amis et qu'ils
n'avaient pas résisté
ça c'est la fleur au chapeau a
photographié l'ararat de l'autre côté a
exposé la photographie et puis après
istanbul c'est washington philby est
premier secrétaire à l'ambassade de
grande bretagne à washington et là il va
être nommé agent de liaison avec la cia
la centrale de l'espionnage américain
comme agent liaison avec la cia il aura
connaissance de tous les secrets de
l'espionnage et du contre-espionnage
américain notamment de toute l'action
américaine
pendant la vie guerre froide car nous
sommes maintenant au plein de la guerre
froide de sorte que tous ses secrets
américains seront transmis régulièrement
aux soviétiques par philby donald mclean
lui après une guerre sans histoire au
foreign office a été envoyé en 44
également à washington et lui il est
nommé secrétaire pour le royaume uni de
la commission mixte pour l'énergie
atomique la commission qui réunit les
américains les anglais de sorte que
donald mclean va se trouver pendant tous
ces mois toutes ces années exactement au
centre de l'information atomique
à une époque où justement les états unis
sont si jaloux de cette information
atomique vous savez c'est l'époque où
depuis 1949
l'union soviétique procès de la banque
une véritable hystérie atomique s'est
soulevé aux états unis on redoute que
les secrets s'en aille
on fait des procès celta moment où des
innocents vont payer des coupables aussi
est à ce moment sans que évidemment
personne puisse en douter il y a là un
homme qui a un laissez-passer permanent
qui lui permet d'entrer quand il veut à
la commission américaine de l'énergie
atomique d'entrer dans les bureaux cuves
de recueillir les renseignements qu'ils
tout ce qu'il veut c'est tom c'est
mclean et tout cela par en ligne se
vêtit je crois qu'il ya eu rarement un
moment dans l'histoire où un certain ce1
certains services secrets a réussi une
pénétration aussi importante dans un
autre réseau secret et puis donald mak
ling par repart pour l'angleterre c'est
burgess qui arrive à washington
décidément les trois amis se retrouvent
là mais progresse ne fait qu'un passage
rapide de là aussi contre lui toujours
son livre à une rixe et petit ami
alors il va repartir bientôt après pas
mal d'aventurés et au moment où il va
partir philby viendra le trouvait lui
dira il faut que vous
avertissions que tu avertissent mclean
quand il rentrera aux et en angleterre
il y à une enquête
on sait qu'il ya des fuites il est
découvert alors averti les élus en guest
pas au départ pour l'angleterre
ils y arrivent au début de mai 51
et c'est vrai à l'instigation des
américains également par la suite d'une
série d' enquêtes du sps on a commencé à
soupçonner fortement mclean qui a été
peut-être trop fort être loin être vite
et le 25 mai on décide 25 mai que c'est
à vendredi lé 25 51
on décide que le 28 mai c'est à dire le
lundi toujours le week end anglais
on commencera interroger sérieusement ma
clé mc lean est perdu alors on sait
aussi que burgess a loué deux couchettes
sur un bateau qui quitte le 25 mai au
soir sous 100 tonnes pour saint malo on
sait que le 25 mai borgas a loué une
austin qui s'est rendu chez les mac line
qu'il a dîné avec mclean les malines
dame est clean et l'on sait que
ils sont partis dans la nuit tous les
deux jusqu'à 60 tonnes il a laissé
l'austin sur le quai il est mon sens
monter tous les deux sur le bateau et
son parti dans la nuit il devait
débarquer à sam alloués par la suite on
perd leur trace
on a raconté que peut-être il s'était
rendu en france à dunkerque où un cargo
soviétique les aurait chargé car
évidemment leur départ était préparé
depuis plusieurs jours alors oui je les
dis le scandale a été immense mais
philby bien philby évidemment quand même
on commence tout de même à parler de lui
c'est chez philby que burgess habitées
quand il était aux états unis on connaît
la limite et des deux hommes burguès
s'est enfui on est sûr maintenant que
burgess était un agent soviétique mclean
dans les têtes et film on n'a aucune
preuve c'est ça la force de films dix
ans les américains eux disent qu'il faut
arrêter filmé à les anglais qui sont
plus prudents plus juriste plus
juridique alors simplement il rappelle
phil bien l'angleterre et simplement de
la cause de ce climat difficile qui
règne lui demande sa démission
c'est l'année d'après en 52 pendant tout
l'été que tout de même on va interroger
philby on va l'interroger longuement des
jours et des jours et disons que ceux
qui l'interrogent sonde des gens forts
qui connaissent leur métier ce sont les
gens qui viennent de démasquer fuchs
l'espion fuchs ils n'arrivent pas
démasqué philby phoebe tient le coup
jusqu'au bout solidement il faut dire
qu'il y ait peut-être aidé par son
bégaiement c'est ce que dira l'un des
agents qui l'a interrogé il vous
comprenez c'est pas facile d'interroger
un b on lui dit ce jour là quel temps
fait il y met cinq minutes à répondre je
utile de vous faire une imitation est en
effet peut-être ce bégaiement et il
était pour quelque chose mais je crois
surtout à une singulière force d'âme
préparez éduquer ressenti est prouvée
alors il n'a plus de situations il fera
de l'import-export sera rédacteur à
l'observer revendre à des pâtes
dentifrices représentant de commerce et
puis en 55 tout à coup c'est la
publication d'un livre blanc sur la
sphère burgess maclean c'est de nouveau
le scandale l'afer qui est de nouveau au
premier plan de l'actualité et un député
à la chambre des communes lipton qui dit
mais enfin est ce que le gouvernement se
décidera à parler en fin du troisième
homme monsieur fumer c'est macmillan qui
va répondre
mclellan qui va répondre eh bien non
mais nous avons fait une enquête sur
monsieur fil du temps sauf monsieur
philby est au dessus de tout soupçon
quentin philby lui il donnera une
conférence de presse chez sa mère sera
interrogé pendant des heures par les
journalistes par la radio par la
télévision et sans dire à s'en tire
admirablement fort bien et l'on dira
même que ce jour là il n'a pas bégayé du
tout comme quoi son bégaiement était
peut-être quelque chose qui était
également savamment utilisée alors après
justement ce nouveau blanchissement il
pas pour beyrouth
là il deviendra correspondante presse
elle est morte il a rencontré encore une
autre femme eleanor elle divorce pour
lui il les pousse à beyrouth
mais plus il va et plus on sent que
c'est un homme à la dérive
il boit de plus en plus il boit comme
abus donc s'il boit comme abu maclean le
signe commun de cette affaire c'est que
les trois héros sont des ivrognes tous
les trois peut-être la tension nerveuse
porté à ce point et pendant tant
d'années
léthel tolérable justement que si on
boit si on boit temps alors nous avons
justement une image de lui
le montre devant sa bouteille
et puis de plus en plus on le soupçonne
ce sont plus que les soupçons
on l'a maintenant la certitude qu'il est
un agent soviétique on arrête un autre
agent soviétique angolais qui s'appelle
george blake on le juge
il est condamné à 42 ans de prison et
ses vannes d'ailleurs deux ans plus tard
il est actuellement à moscou et le
procès de blake a mis en avant le rôle
probable de philby et on lui envoie un
agent qui l'interrogent de nouveau à
beyrouth il ne craque pas et puis on
descend 1962 un deuxième agent il a ce
deuxième agent fait tant et tant que
philby cac
le 23 janvier 1963 fils biais sa femme
ont un dîner en ville à beyrouth
ils sont dans un taxi pour aller à cette
idée tout à coup philby annonce à sa
femme il faut s'arrêter je doivent
envoyer un câble
je te rejoins tout à l'heure chez nos
amis le taxi s'arrête et là on ne le
verra pas ce soir là non plus que les
autres soient revenir philby les parties
il est parti pour moscou où on le
retrouve quelques jours plus tard il ne
reverra pas burgess à moscou burgess qui
après s'être acclimaté avoir mené une
vie paradoxal de dandy britannique en
pleine union soviétique bien dog est
très malade et est en train de mourir il
est mort justement 63 avant que puisses
te revoir philby mes fils vivent à
retrouver mclean qui est fonctionnaire
au ministère des affaires étrangères
soviétique
il va retrouver également melinda
melinda mclean qui avait rejoint avec
ses enfants
mclean en 1950 3 et puis elle est alors
va le rejoindre elle va vivre avec lui
avec philby jusqu'en 1965 et puis elle
en aura assez elle partira repartira et
lui alors viendra vivre avec
avec qui est bien avec madame mclean et
oui madame mclean qui quittera son mari
pour retrouver philby fils vit
décidément un ma femme jusqu'au bout qui
aura toujours
toujours des femmes y'a que le pauvre
maxime qui est tout seul mais en face à
c'est une autre histoire
alors ils sont là on peut les voir à
moscou et fils bill répond facilement ou
demandes d'interview il vit
confortablement j'ai rencontré son fils
récemment john philby qui m'a parlé de
son père tel qu'il est à moscou il m'a
parlé de son bel appartement de 4 à 5
pièces avec tout le confort avec
machines à laver et télévisions
frigidaire il est très bien traité il
est bien payé les conseillers conseiller
en coin tu sais pas trop il est
conseillé voilà que tout ce qui reste de
la sphère philby d'orgueil matlin
évidemment une sensationnelle histoire
d' aventure mais eux qu'est ce qu'on
peut penser de ces trois hommes eh bien
peut-être qu'ils sont le fruit très
directe de notre siècle
nous ne vivons pas un siècle facile nous
avons vécu le temps où tous les
principes traditionnels ou à peu près
ont été remis en question alors heureux
ces trois hommes ont remis peut-être
encore plus de principe que d'autres en
question c'est peut-être cela leurs
excuses
ils n'ont pas touché d'argent
cela peut-être c'est une autre excuse
est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui mon dieu ils manifestent
tout au moins les deux survivants philby
et mclean sorte de confort moral mais
malgré tout
c'est dans ton ils disaient qu'on n'en
porte pas sa patrie à la semelle de ses
souliers
je crois que eux ils ont fait plus que
l'emporter à la semelle de leurs
souliers
alors malgré cet apparent confort moral
moi je suis persuadé qu'il reste au fond
d'eux-mêmes ce quelque chose d'infiniti
mal qui est au fond de chacun de nous et
qui fait que quelquefois quand il se
regarde dans une glace
ils sont peut-être pas à l'aise avec eux
mêmes
[Musique]